gewinnen ist leicht verlieren ist
niemals leicht nicht für mich sagt
donald trump in geradezu aufreizender
offenheit die logik eines
immobilienmaklers verständlich aber in
der politik gehört verlieren dazu
was also wenn ein immobilienmakler
politiker wird das ist gerade in den usa
zu beobachten wo ein endgültiges
wahlergebnis nach wie vor aussteht aber
donald trumps sich bereits zum sieger
erklärt hat nach der us wahl wohin
steuert amerika jetzt in der phoenix
runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns liebe
zuschauer meine gäste zunächst hier im
studio e mail alliance ist bei uns ist
stammen aus indiana aus dem
us-bundesstaat ein tramp staat arbeiten
beim max planck institut für
demokratieforschung und sind
stellvertretende vorsitzende von
demokrat sports das ist die in berlin
das ist die auslandsorganisation der
us-demokraten frank meyer ist schweizer
publizist und kolumnist lebt in berlin
und schreibt unter anderem für das
magazin cicero zugeschaltet aus
washington ist die leiterin des dortigen
studios der deutschen welle ines pohl
und aus hannover benjamin wolf meyer
deutschland sprecher von republicans
overseas das ist die
auslandsorganisation der us-republikaner
bevor wir jetzt hier los legen liebe
zuschauer noch mal ganz kurz einen blick
auf zwei ganz wichtige äußerungen der
kandidaten in der vergangen nach die im
wesentlichen die problematik der um wir
uns heute gegenübersehen ganz kurz und
knapp zusammenfassen
das ist eine wirklich traurige der
gruppe von menschen versucht diese
zu fälschen
wir werden wir werden dies gewinnen und
wir haben es eigentlich schon gewonnen
[Musik]
ich bin hier um ihnen zu sagen dass wir
auf dem weg sind diese wahl zu gewinnen
weder sie noch ich werden erklären wer
die wahl gewonnen hat sondern das ist
die entscheidung des amerikanischen
volkes so das hat schon bei mir heute
abend noch einmal wiederholt in seiner
kurzen ansprache ines pohl welche rolle
spielt joe biden eigentlich jetzt seit
gestern wenn man das mit donald trump
vergleicht in der ja in der sicht in der
analyse auf das wahlergebnis
sie war gestern abend vor dem weißen
haushaltszucker mehr oder weniger ja
sein sieg verkündet hat und versucht hat
sozusagen die öffentliche meinung zu
dominieren das narrativ an sich zu
reissen joe biden hat gestern und jetzt
gerade wir haben es gehört ist genaue
gegenteil versucht er sagt schon dass er
davon ausgeht dass er die entsprechenden
mehrheiten hat aber er stellt in den
mittelpunkt seiner aussagen die aufgabe
dieses land wieder zusammenzubringen zu
versöhnen er sagt bei jeder gelegenheit
ich bin ein kandidat ein präsident für
alle amerikanerinnen und amerikaner
und ich glaube es ist die wichtigste
aufgabe die der künftige präsident zu
erfüllen hat insofern versucht er
wirklichen gegen narrativ zu donald
trump zu etablieren
der wolf meyer lassen sie uns doch an
der gedankenwelt von donald trump markus
theil haben der ja sagt es soll nicht
alle stimmen ausgezählt werden die
auszählung in michigan in pennsylvania
soll jetzt gestoppt werden nach seinem
willen eigentlich gehen ja die wähler
davon aus dass die stimme die ich abgebe
bei einer wahl auch mitgezählt werden
warum will donald trump das nicht na ja
das problem bei der ganzen sache ist ja
dass die demokraten das ganze von langer
hand geplant haben als sie vor fünf
monaten beschlossen haben die wahlzeiten
zu erhöhen die registrierung
abzuschaffen
also die ganzen wahlgesetze für die
briefwahl ja verändert haben und wir
sehen ja wie ist jetzt
unregelmäßigkeiten in wisconsin und in
michigan gab der präsident hat nicht nur
das beste ergebnis anders republikaners
überhaupt erzielt hat historische
erfolge in florida erzielt und in
großstädten wie miami detroit und
philadelphia ein historisches ergebnis
bei schwarzen und hispanics woher so gut
abgeschnitten hat wie kein republikaner
seit den 60ern und wir werden uns diesen
wahlsieg auch nicht wegnehmen lassen
oder wegdiskutieren lassen
er führt in pennsylvania deutlich und er
wird auch arizona noch gewinnen und in
north carolina und georgia auch vorne
und nicht mehr einholbar und alaska
sowieso
das heißt also sie können dann könnten
ja auch die restlichen stimmen in
pennsylvania michigan ausgezählt werden
wenn sie sicher sind dass deutschland
gewinnt es geht darum dass nach dem
wahltag nicht noch irgendwelche stimmen
die von irgendwoher kommen ausgezählt
werden ja von wählern leute hatten lange
genug zeit zu wählen und man hatte auch
genug zeit zum auszählen jetzt noch mit
irgendwelchen stimmen anzukommen man
sieht das ja wie das in michigan
wisconsin gewesen ist dass in der nacht
140.000 in wisconsin und 200.000
indische gerne aufgetaucht sind
das werden wir so nicht hinnehmen
michigan geht ja hans gericht weiter die
werden dann entscheiden
in wisconsin gibt es jetzt eine neue
auszählung und dann werden wir
weitersehen
aber wir werden das nicht zulassen dass
im nachhinein das wählervotum verändert
also mutmaßlicher weise kamen ja diese
stimmen auch nicht von irgendwo her
sondern von den briefwählern zum
beispiel frauleins dieses ganze gezerre
um den wahlausgang gehen wir jetzt
gerade erleben wäre ja eigentlich
überflüssig hätte show beiden ihr
kandidat so abgeschnitten wie eigentlich
die umfragen es vorhergesagt haben also
eigentlich ist das verbreiten ja auch ja
nicht ein misserfolge wissen noch nicht
wie es ausgeht aber so richtig
erfolgreich hatte diese wahl auch nicht
absolviert
also ich würde solche aussagen noch
nicht zustimmen also wir waren immer
noch bis jeder stimme gezählt wird und
wie herr wolf mann gemeint also dass wir
der prozess geändert haben nur einfach
so das stimmt nicht wir leben momentan
in ein pandemie wir wussten vorher alle
wussten vorher dass fehler per briefwahl
wählen mussten deshalb haben wir das
gemacht und haben auch alle verstanden
und herbert meyer wenn sie wählen könnte
wenn sie das auch verstehen das ist
nicht so einfach mit der post ball
moment weil er auch geschwächt und
deshalb haben wir das so gemacht dass
viele stimmen gezählt werden
trotzdem ist das gute angebot nur weil
der passt jetzt haben sie die frau laut
allerdings meine frage in ihrer antwort
wunderbar um schicht ich hatte ja gesagt
eigentlich hätte er war ja erwartet
worden durch die umfrage dass schon bei
relativ klar gewinnt da war das nicht
der fall klar aber erstens wir gucken
erst mal wer das komplett aus geht aber
zweitens ich glaube alle haben gelernt
2006 sehen wir können nicht immer jeder
umfrage vertrauen
wir müssen einfach abwarten und gucken
was genau eigentlich passiert wenn man
ja in einem online-artikel war heute
zulegen lesen dass angesichts dieser
unklaren situation in den usa in berlin
jetzt langsam panik unter der
politischen klasse ausbrechen würde da
hat man ja ein anderes ergebnis erwartet
was bedeutet jetzt überhaupt diese
ereignisse bekennen das ergebnis ja noch
nicht was bedeuten jetzt diese
ereignisse jenseits des atlantiks
eigentlich für deutschland und für
europa wenn wir jetzt davon ausgehen
dass es beiden wäre würde ich sagen es
sollte keine beruhigung bedeuten
es sollte nicht das gefühl hervorrufen
es ist jetzt alles wie vorher wie das
war vor trump das wäre ganz falsch denn
trump ist ein ereignis von historischer
bedeutung dass es nicht irgendeiner der
da weniger weise zufälligerweise
präsident wurde sondern dass man das
analysiert müsste man ja sagen
irgendjemand hat ja die grundlagen
gelegt dass der gewählt wurde das waren
ganz sicher auch demokraten also ich
meine jetzt von der partei
also das war schon mal eine
verpflichtung wenn beiden präsident
würde mal zu studieren warum kam es
soweit welches ist unsere verantwortung
und wir hier in deutschland sowieso als
schweiz erstaunlich wie einseitig rampe
vier jahre betrachtet wird also auf eine
für journalisten peinlicherweise also
ich meine für journalisten da in
deutschland war obama der mann der übers
wasser gehen konnte kein recht gefragt
ob er übers wasser geht weil er nicht
schwimmen kann
also man hat sich nicht überlegt was war
da falsch es war die auch etwas fahl und
das finde ich dass wir wesentlich sollte
tromp es wird müsste man sich überlegen
donnerwetter die haben weiterhin so
gewählt
sie haben sie am abend hätten sie haben
sagt dieter meyer wir werden noch
darüber reden welchen knick in der optik
möglicherweise europäischer und die
deutschen blick auf donald trump haben
ines pohl was macht das eigentlich mit
einer demokratie wenn wir mal noch beim
grundsätzlichen bleiben wenn der oberste
repräsentant von betrug und diebstahl
spricht das hat er ja heute nacht getan
und zwar ausgerechnet beim herzstück der
demokratie bei der wahl oder beim
wahlgang
ja es ist ganz gefährlich das erleben
wir ja schon seit monaten trampert ja
sozusagen die rampe schon lange
vorbereitet die er jetzt beschreitet
diese wahl zu unterminieren in dem fall
in dem er verliert und ich hatte die
möglichkeit die vergangenen sieben
wochen dieses große wunderbare amerika
zu bereisen und wir haben ganz ganz oft
gehört sozusagen auswendig gelernte
setzte die donald trump in die
öffentlichkeit gegeben hat wenn mein
donald trump nicht gewinnt dann kann es
nur passiert sein weil diese diese
demokraten die wahl gestohlen haben weil
wir hier wahlbetrug erleben und es ist
natürlich höchst problematisch wenn der
präsident am abend der wahl sein
sieg mehr oder wenig verkündet obwohl
hunderttausende von stimmen noch nicht
ausgezählt worden sind und der wild maa
kurzen replik zu ihnen sie wissen dass
hoffentlich das in pennsylvania das
gesetz vorsieht dass stimmen ausgezählt
werden können die noch am wahltag per
post eingegangen sind und ich weiß nicht
wann sie das letzte mal in den
vereinigten staaten waren
ich habe mit ganz vielen
familienangehörigen gesprochen die die
menschen an corona die
familienangehörige an dem corona virus
verloren haben wir haben über 250
tausend tote amerikanerinnen und
amerikaner
und ich finde man darf da wirklich nicht
zynisch sein und das recht auf eine
briefwahl mit irgendwelchen politischen
machenschaften in verbindung bringen das
beschützt das herzstück der demokratie
wählen zu gehen und haben sich viele
staaten entschieden den menschen zu
ermöglichen obwohl du sagst ich auch
nicht wahrzunehmen weil weil sie sich
nicht infizieren wollten und deswegen
ist es finde ich einfach zynisch zu
behaupten dass die demokraten da
irgendwelche politischen spielchen
betrieben haben ist also das wahrlich in
pennsylvania glaube ich hat sich
dergestalt in einem moment da muss man
das wahlrecht in pennsylvania glaube ich
ist so man muss am dritten november mit
poststempel abgeschickt haben man kann
das glaube ich sogar noch bis freitag
muss es im wahlkreisbüro dann eingehen
wollten wir ja sie haben vorhin gesagt
wir lassen uns den sieg nicht nehmen
donald trump und die republikaner das
hat jetzt praktisch gleich lautende ja
wir haben vorhin ja gehört am abend auch
joe biden noch mal gesagt also beide
lassen sich den sieg nicht nehmen das
ist ja auch noch nicht endgültig
ausgezählt findet jetzt eine
schlammschlacht stadt die quasi den
wahlkampf weiter fortsetzt
nein also als schlammschlacht empfinde
ich das nicht ich finde es ganz normal
dass jeder jetzt um sein sieg noch
kämpft es stehen ja wie gesagt noch
genug starten aus obwohl also north
carolina alaska und georgia eigentlich
klar für trump sind da ist überhaupt gar
keine möglichkeit mehr für joe biden
diese zu gewinnen
und in pennsylvania und ich habe das
auch nicht getan frau pohl ich war
ich habe überhaupt nicht über die leute
gesprochen die durch kroner einen lieben
menschen verloren haben wir das zu
unterstellen finde ich schon sehr heftig
von ihnen da bin ich eigentlich besser
es von ihnen gewohnt journalisten
aber es geht doch darum es gibt es gab
vor es gab rief wahlmöglichkeiten seit
mitte september ist gab das early voting
es gab den stichtag der wahl und danach
ist dann normalerweise schluss stellen
sie sich mal vor in deutschland würde
die spd irgendwie knapp die wahl
gewinnen und dann würde die cdu sagen
wir haben aber noch stimmen in passau
und in dresden was dann in dieser
republik los wäre die dann noch 40
gezielt werden 123 tage in nevada können
sie bis zu zehn tage nach der wahl sogar
das war andere verhältnisse sind und die
staaten unterschiedliche gesetze haben
und das absolut legitim ist dass die
stimmen der arbeiten diese gelder dann
noch gezählt
dadurch weisen freitag dünn gegangen
sind es ist einfach recht und wie sehr
wohl in zu sagen dieses recht ist
gebrochen und politisch genau das
punktelose ist einfach falsch
obwohl das ist falsch was sie sagen
diese gesetze wurden fünf monate vor der
wahl gemacht also das ist doch ganz
offensichtlich was der hintergrund war
wenn ich fünf monate vor einer wahl in
nur bestimmten staaten und nicht in
allen bundesstaaten nämlich nur da wo
ich die gouverneure habe um die gesetze
einfach durchwinken zu können die
wahlgesetze für die briefwahl ändere
also deutlicher geht es doch also ich
meines wissens sind diese wahlgesetze ja
auch deswegen geändert worden dass
möglichst viele leute die bis dahin
nicht zur wahl gehen konnten also vor
allem aus minderheiten jetzt in zukunft
leichter zugang zur wahl haben zur
registrierung und zur wahl und je mehr
menschen in einer demokratie wählen
können umso besser also jedenfalls hatte
ich das so verstanden würde ich möchte
diesen jungen händler und kollegen oder
war es auch immer mal als schweizer eine
antwort geben müsse ja garnicht grenzen
ich finde es eine ungeheuerlichkeit
welche unterstellungen
sie machen sind reine unterstellung von
demokratie verstehen was und ich bin
nicht einer der zwar oft ihre keller und
ich kann konnte trump immer etwas
abgewinnen konnte dran bin mir etwas
abgewinnen aber was ich jetzt höre ist
eine ungeheuerlichkeit die empört mich
zutiefst
es gibt allerdings dafür auch eine
erklärung und erhält sie haben sie
angetönt er ist ein mann der deals macht
dagegen ist nichts einzuwenden solange
man nicht die politik auf dies reduziert
für ihn ist eine wahl verliert den deal
also akzeptiert der ihn nicht das ist
ganz normales verhalten von leuten die
deals machen und wir wissen seit vier
jahren ist der begriff was ist für
politische aktionen und übrigens noch
mal die journalistin habe den begriff so
total übernommen werden jetzt auch von
deal politik ist kein deal politik ist
ein sache mit klaren regeln und
prozessual und was hier passiert ist er
beharrt auf dem reflex das ist ein deal
denn misslingt mir das kann nur
schwindel seien nämlich nicht akzeptiere
ich nichts geht zum richter das ist eine
mentalität die ich überhaupt nicht
verstehe
an meinem tiefsten demokratischen innen
heraus
wir haben ja er auch in europa
gelegentlich politische aktivitäten
politische entscheidungen die dann bei
gerichten landen ist das sagen ein ganz
normaler prozess dass man sich jetzt
richter anruf bei allen gelegenheiten
eben jetzt auch den usa zu sagen wir
können und sich einigen der wähler hat
sich nicht deutlich ausgedrückt nach
unserer ansicht sollen doch die gerichte
entscheiden es gibt in jedem der
bundesstaaten 50 verschiedene wahlrechte
in den usa in 50 bundesstaaten plus
washington dc gibt es einen eigenen
supreme court und dann gibt es noch
bundesweit einen das heißt also in
zukunft entscheiden die gerichte wer die
wahlen gewinnt die legitimation der
demokratie liegt beim volk nicht
berichten
lassen sie uns auf einen aspekt noch
nicht online
ich würde gerne einen anderen aspekt
ansprechen der aber auch wichtig ist
glaube ich auch für die republikaner
die wahlforscher die demoskopen scheinen
ja ähnlich wie 2016 da wieder ins klo
gegriffen zu haben denn man hat ja
vorher gesagt dass dort das das arbeiten
ist klar gewinnt jetzt wiederholt sich
quasi 2016
woran liegt das eigentlich warum sind
die sind die demoskopen in usa nicht in
der lage einen einigermaßen
authentischen einigermaßen wasserdichte
vorhersage zu machen und liegen wieder
so daneben ihre eigene partei hat sich
da auch aufs glatteis führen lassen und
sich vorab gefreut und jetzt wird
möglicherweise das ganze entweder ganz
knapp oder vielleicht auch noch für
donald trump ausgehen also ich glaube
bei uns also zumindest die demokraten
die im ausland sind wir waren immer sehr
vorsichtig optimistisch weil wir wussten
wie gesagt was in 2006 in passiert ist
aber ich glaube auch fehler träumt
anhängern anhängerin leider nicht die
wahrheit sollte für sollte umfragen
sagen wollen also irgendwie gibt es
immer noch so ein jahr die denken dass
sie werden so schlecht angeguckt werden
wenn die sagen ich werde dann
unterstützen und deshalb glaube ich sind
die werte irgendwie falsch
apropos gibt es denn da was die
demoskopin den usa angeht es ist jetzt
aufgefallen auf dem sarg war ja auch in
den sechs kritik der demoskopen in den
letzten stunden zu hören die dann gesagt
haben ja bei uns ist so der typische
trump wähler man weiß ohne
college-abschluss eigentlich
unterrepräsentiert in diesem panel das
sind ja nur ein paar tausend leute der
befragt werden und die dann sozusagen
repräsentative die ganze bevölkerung
sein das schon zum zweiten mal so
daneben lag mit einer vorhersage und das
wahlergebnis völlig anders war also zum
einen ist es nicht völlig anders nur das
ist einfach
es liegt an dem der wahlsystem in den
vereinigten staaten welches
sehr anders ist gegenüber den deutschen
wahlsystem
dadurch dass der gewinner alle
wahlmänner wahlfrauen stimme eines
staates krieg kann das können dass
wenige tausend stimmen seien die so eine
ganze wahl entscheiden wir in uns
vielleicht vor 2001 vor 2000 jahren
so weit so lange ist es auch noch nicht
offensichtlich allein 3000 hat bush die
wahl mit nur 500 stimmen vorsprung in
florida am ende für sich entscheiden
können vor vier jahren waren es nur
45.000 stimmen die donald trump in
pennsylvania die wahl nach hause
gebracht haben also das kann daran
liegen aber ich glaube es ist ganz
wichtig uns zu vergegenwärtigen warum
menschen donald trump wählen und ist
meiner meinung nach wird zu wenig von
demoskopen aber durchaus auch von
journalistinnen und journalisten
berücksichtigt es gibt ganz viele männer
und frauen in den vereinigten staaten
die donald trump donald trump jeweils
nur aus einem grund wählen manche wählen
ihn weil sie gegen abtreibungen sind
andere wählen ihn weil sie sich von ihm
versprechen dass er für die freiheit
waffen zu tragen kämpfen wird andere
wählen ihn weil er dafür sorge trägt
dass sie weniger steuern zahlen müssen
und ich glaube demoskopen machen häufig
den fehler dass sie davon ausgehen dass
sind mehrere gründe die dann am ende für
die entscheidung wichtig sind es ist
anders in diesem land ganz viele
menschen wählen ihren kandidaten nur aus
einem einzigen grund der wolf meyer wenn
sie fühlt sich jetzt fühlen sich die
republikaner fühlt sich donald trump
eigentlich bestätigt in ihrer haltung
gegen eliten gegen das gesellschaftliche
establishment zu sein wenn man jetzt bei
dem bei diesen demoskopischen
untersuchungen dem wahlergebnis im
vergleich sieht das doch für viele
journalisten auch so viele wahlforscher
die gefühle die lebenswirklichkeit der
amerikaner des amerikanischen
durchschnittsbürger ist ziemlich weit
weg sind
also ich muss natürlich erst mal
stellung dazu nehmen was hat man ja
gesagt hat haben wir ja ich habe nicht
von schwindel gesprochen das haben sie
haben gesagt ja mit pinsel gießen
und gelegentlich harmony mund gelegt ich
habe nicht von schweren haben von
bestellungen habe ich so verstanden ja
nicht dass wir noch über ganz kurz
stellung dazu und dann würde ich sie
bitten auf meine frage noch zu
beantworten ja natürlich aber
entschuldigung ich hatte ja ein paar mal
versucht eben direkt zu erwidern haben
sie mich ja nicht angenommen ich muss
darauf schon noch mal eingehen ich habe
ja lediglich versucht zu erklären warum
wir jetzt dagegen vorgehen werden dass
bestimmte stimmen noch irgendwie gezählt
werden
das war ja ihre frage vorhin gewesen und
ich habe das einfach mal versucht zu
erklären warum in rees konnten noch mal
neu ausgezählt wird und warum michigan
nochmal vor die gerichte geht und da
dann entschieden wird aber es steht auch
völlig außer frage dass wenn am ende die
nase vorn haben sollte natürlich wird
dann das amt das wie jeder andere
präsident zuvor auch dann akzeptieren
und die niederlage eingestehen
aber es ist noch nicht zu ende es sind
sehr viele staaten wo donald trump führt
so dass die beiden gleichauf sind
elektro college und jetzt warten wir
noch ab wir haben jetzt so lange auf
diese wahl gewartet jetzt haben wir noch
zwei drei tage zeit um das endgültige
ergebnis zu haben und das dann zu
akzeptieren
erstmal habe ich das richtig verstanden
ganz kurz das hier das donald trump hat
er gesagt er hat gewonnen
sie sagen jetzt also wenn sich
rausstellt dass beiden nach der
auszählung der stimmen und vor allem der
zusammensetzung des elektronisches also
der des wahlmänner gremiums die nase
vorn hat dann wird donald trump auch den
sieg von joe biden akzeptieren natürlich
wenn wenn die gerichte in musikern das
so oder so entscheiden wenn die
neuauszählung in wisconsin das ergibt
und falls arizona es hängt ja jetzt sehr
viel an arizona arizona dann doch an joe
biden geht dann
ist das so und das werden natürlich wir
und vor allem auch der präsident
natürlich akzeptieren das stand auch nie
in frage und steht es auch jetzt nicht
zu ihrer frage zurück natürlich fühlt
man sich bestätigt mit dem establishment
das ist ja auch eins der großen
wahlkampfthemen 2016 gewesen
und das ist natürlich noch nicht vorbei
also bei der zweiten amtszeit wird auch
das natürlich ein großes thema sein
den sumpf in washington anzugehen
bestimmte verkrustungen in bestimmten
system strukturen einfach aufzubrechen
da ist ja schon ein bisschen was
passiert mit den lobbyisten und so
weiter aber das natürlich längst noch
nicht fertig also das ist ja ein
langzeitprojekt würde ich mal sagen
insofern kann ich das nur bejahen formel
1 haben die demokraten auf die falschen
themen gesetzt
zwar vor allen dingen es geht um corona
die pandemie um die verfehlte politik
der us regierung also des präsidenten
sie haben das immer wieder eben donald
trump vorgeworfen es ging auch um die
behandlung ethnischer minderheiten black
live matters wenn man sich jetzt mal
ansieht was den leuten wichtig war bei
der wahl spielten diese beiden themen er
nur eine zweite sekundäre rolle eine
zweite geige am wichtigsten war die
wirtschaft und da haben offenbar viele
donald trump mehr zugetraut als joe
biden hand wieder auf die falschen
themen gesetzt das glaube ich nicht also
ich glaube ohne die pandemie zu
konfrontieren kommt man auch nicht
weiter so es gibt natürlich ganz viele
themen was wir ansprechen können das
haben die wahrscheinlich auch irgendwann
gemacht aber das war nicht die
hauptthemen beim momentan leben wir in
einer welt wo es gibt ein pandemie die
leute können nicht so richtig raus gehen
essen gehen freunde familie treffen und
das müssen wir erst mal angehen und der
präsident hat das nicht gemacht und
deshalb hat die beiden das angebot
gemacht
gut aber offensichtlich hat ja damit
donald trump einen nerv getroffen bei
vielen der ihnen dann doch die stimmen
eingebracht hat mit denen er dann ganz
nah an schreitenden zumindestens
herangerückt ist also ist ganz sicher so
dass nicht einfach die ich
und stellt jetzt wohl nichts aber es
jetzt so aufgezählt die waffen wollen
und also eigentlich so denn die
primitive teil welt weil trump so ist es
überhaupt nicht
es gibt gründe jump zu verhelfen sogar
leute die sagen wir brauchen die
konfrontation mit china das nach dem
prinzip der 3k funktioniert kaufen
klauen kopieren und das lassen wir uns
nicht mehr bieten da hat natürlich trump
diese app island politik der demokraten
übrigens der deutschen ganz europas hat
er konterkariert aber immer das problem
bei ihm ist er sieht den punkt ich habe
das mal so beschrieben ich habe oft zu
tun mit immobilien leuten und die können
einen vertrag gucken und auf jeder seite
sehen sie ohne zu lesen genau der punkt
der der schwerpunkt das sind meine übung
sagt das ja auch gar nicht lange gelesen
und das kann er den punkt 10 hat einige
punkte gesehen das war ganz ganz wichtig
und dann wird ist er kein politiker kam
nicht dass politik ist ein handwerk
politik ist eine einübung ich habe
gesagt sie ist prozessual zeit haben die
sache vorbereiten umsichtig sein das
sind alles nicht kriterien von ihm er
ist ein geschäftsmann des
immobilienhandels gibt auch andere
geschäftsmänner die an das operieren
müssen aber er ist letztlich unpolitisch
hat dabei eine gigantische politische
wirkung und nicht nur eine schlechte und
diejenigen die finden dass ist gut haben
vielleicht gar keine waffe gewollt aber
sie wollten gegenüber china
beispielsweise eine andere politik das
heißt raum zu unterschätzt worden auch
von seinen politischen gegner in espoo
wenn wir noch mal auf die demokraten den
usa schauen sind sie wieder opfer ihrer
nicht durchdachten strategie sage ich
mal so geworden wie schon bei der wahl
2016 da gibt es also die gedankenwelt
und die anhängerschaft das ist die
politische elite an der ostküste die
kulturelle elite an der westküste und
darüber dass so genannten zwischen der
sogenannte fly over country dass man nur
mit dem flugzeug überquert um
los angeles nach new york zu kommen hat
man da einfach zu wenig das herzstück
amerikas der mittlere westen gilt ja als
solches zu wenig im auge gehabt um
tatsächlich mehrheitsfähig zu werden
dass eben die usa nicht nur aus den
küstenregionen besteht sondern auch aus
dem land dazwischen ganz wichtiger punkt
den sie ansprechen und auch mein
vorredner donald trump für stets
einzelne angebote zu machen die dann bei
wichtigen bella blocks verfangen
joe biden hat nichts im angebot das
einzige was er im angebot hat ist eine
knapp 50 jährige vergangenheit die genau
auch wieder dieses narrativ bedient es
sind die alten eliten auf die wir
eigentlich keine lust mehr haben und er
hat sich präsentiert als ein
versöhnendes präsident noch mal ich
glaube dass dieses land dieses
versöhnende momentum unbedingt braucht
um wieder eine gute friedliche zukunft
zu kommen aber das verfängt natürlich
nicht mehr männer und bei männern und
frauen die wählerinnen und wählern in
dieser wirtschaftlichen situation auch
das müssen wir uns vergegenwärtigen die
situation hier in den vereinigten
staaten ist schon jetzt brutal und wird
noch viel schlimmer werden ganz viele
menschen haben ihre arbeit schon jetzt
verloren
wir wissen es gibt hier wirklich nicht
dieses soziale netzwerk wie in
deutschland die leute verlieren mit
ihrem arbeitsplatz die ihre
gesundheitsvorsorge im januar werden wir
eine welle an ankündigungen sehen die
selbst in so einer reichen stadt wie
washington stehen jetzt schon überall
die zelte in denen die menschen wohnen
weil sie ihre häuser verlassen müssen
weil sie die miete nicht mehr bezahlen
können uns kaum mieterschutz gibt und
hier hatte muss man ganz ehrlich so
sagen jo walden wenig zu bieten er ist
ein kompromiss konnten kandidat versucht
ein mann der mitte zu finden der
anschlussfähig ist an alle seiten aber
das hat wieder mal überhaupt nicht
funktioniert und da müssen wir oder darf
nur sagen dass donald trump und sein
team eine viel bessere politische agenda
aufgesetzt haben die einfach besser
verfängt können sie dann aus ihren
erfahrenen usa bestätigten dass den die
amerikaner so sehr dass denen so sehr
die freiheit am herzen liegt dass sie
auf jede soziale sicherheit pfeifen es
kommt auch darauf an der amerikaner wer
ist der amerikaner aber es ist in der
tat so die freiheit keine
krankenversicherung haben zu müssen
liegt vor manche menschen schwerer als
eine krankenversicherung zu haben das
ist für uns deutsche glaube ich ganz
schwer nachvollziehbar aber der staat
hier soll klein gehalten werden und auch
diese angst vor dem übermächtigen
vielleicht auch sozialistischen staat
hat donald trump unglaublich gut
gespielt ganz viele hatten angst dass
plötzlich mit joe biden und camilla
harris der sozialismus einkehrt in den
vereinigten staaten ich glaube beide
stehen überhaupt nicht dafür aber ja es
gibt ja ein ganz großes freiheits
bedürfnis das ist richtig ganz tief
verortet und was wird der kollege der
republikanischen partei sicher
bestätigen dafür kämpfen die menschen
und das möchten sie sich nicht wegnehmen
lassen und es hat joe biden hat es nicht
geschafft diese angst zu zerstören
er wolle jetzt hat ja dieses
wahlergebnis von gestern eines wiesn das
eben donald trump kein betriebsunfall
der geschichte war selbst wenn er jetzt
nicht mehr bei der präsident ist er hat
möglicherweise die usa ganz neu
ausgerichtet die amerikanische
gesellschaft in eine ganz andere
richtung wie sieht denn die usa aus wie
sie sich das oder die sich die
republikaner die sich donald trump das
jetzt vorstellen für die zukunft was ist
der unterschied zu unseren bisherigen
usa bild es ist halt nicht mehr die usa
die der weltpolizist spielt die
militärische konflikte anfang ich meine
es war der erste präsident seit 40
jahren der keinen neuen krieg begonnen
hat kriegs konflikte beendet hat
friedensabkommen für israel organisiert
hat und die truppen aus den letzten
konflikten abzieht
das wird sich ändern die haltung zu
china ja dass man härtere position
gegenüber china ergreift da ist ja auch
sehr viel erreicht worden das erste
handelsabkommen mit china hat ja sehr
sehr viele positive aspekte und zweites
war in bearbeitung und dann kann
die krone auch das wäre natürlich ein
thema wo man weiter daran arbeiten auch
noch muss es ja auch noch weiter gehen
muss
auch das wäre eine große veränderung die
wichtig nicht nur für die usa sondern
auch eigentlich für europa denn 3m hat
da vieles gemacht was europa im prinzip
auch bemängelt aber selber sich nicht
traut die hände schmutzig zu machen oder
in den kampf zu gehen und dann aber sich
auch noch zurücklehnt und ihn für die
art und weise wie er diesen kampf führt
dann auch noch kritisiert das ist schon
ja das ist schon sehr traurig obwohl die
europa auch davon profitiert gerade was
china betrifft ich würde das gerne ich
gehe nicht dass gleich noch mal auf was
man ja aber fräuleins werden die
demokraten in den usa jetzt sozusagen
das gegenmodell zu dem zu dieser skizze
die wolfmaier da gerade gezeigt hat sein
dass sie also sozusagen das andere
amerika repräsentieren wollen dass hier
die frage
wenn dieses land so gespalten ist wenn
der ist so tief geht in dieser
gesellschaft dass der durch diese
unterschiedlichen auffassungen
überzeugungen noch weiter vertieft wird
ich glaub schon also es gibt eine
spaltung das haben wir gesehen und wir
alle haben eine verschiedene idee was
wichtig ist für unser land was wir
zuerst adressieren sollen und ich muss
auch sagen also mehr karin die indianer
aufgewachsen bin
die auch gerade anfang oktober da waren
ich kann auch sagen also ich komme aus
von einer dieser fly over states und ich
kenne egal dass wir nicht in der
mehrheit sind die demokraten auch leute
die ähnliche ideen haben will sind mehr
geworden also es gibt viele leute die
sich jetzt engagieren und ich weiß meine
eigene tante onkel die in den 70er schon
70 cent
die haben sich schon in 2008 den
wahlkampf gemacht für ihre senator und
die haben sich richtig zur tour gegangen
und mit leute geredet ich glaube egal
dass wenn ich in der mehrheit sind wir
sind auf dem weg die leute sich da zu
engagieren die sind nicht nur die ligen
diesem kurs die ost- und westküste
wohnen die unter partie stimmen ist es
wirklich auch die leute die in der mitte
sind wir jetzt auf den europa
oder deutschen aspekt dessen was auch
benjamin wolf meyer gerade gesagt hat
noch einmal blicken wir haben uns 1990
zurückgelehnt friedensdividende kassiert
amerikaner bezahlen unsere sicherheit
ändert sich das jetzt auch unabhängig
davon ob jetzt trump im amt bleibt oder
beiden das wird wird sich da etwas
ändern werden die europäer mehr
verantwortung übernehmen müssen nicht
nur finanziell sondern auch politisch
sich etwas neues bauen müssen
ich bin überzeugt dass sie das tun
werden und dass das ist das liegt auf
der hand dass sie das tun müssen denn
die weltpolitischen konflikte werden
mehr sein wir haben jetzt 30 jahre fasst
der ruhe hinter uns wenn sie nur denken
trump hat tatsächlich als einziger kein
krieg entfesselt aber vielleicht wird
sich in den nächsten vier jahren die
frage stellen wie die amerikanischen
flotte unterstützt vielleicht von den
franzosen die sind ja die einzige die
noch ernst zu nehmen sind in europa
punkto militär sicher nicht da ich
deutschland ob wir da taiwan bewahren
müssen und zwar manu military bewahren
müssen
vor dieser digital statistischen
diktatur das sind wenn jetzt von china
und ich rede von china wird auch jeder
verstanden haben das ist also das hätte
sich stalin nicht erträumt was die
können das ist genial und da ist ein
feind das ist ein feind der offene
gesellschaft und mit dem werden wir
konfrontiert seien nicht nur einfach so
handelspolitische sonne
das ist eine macht die auch waffen
einsetzen wird gerade gegenüber der
einzigen demokratie das alpine da waren
ist eine chinesische demokratie die
funktionierte seiner rechtsstaat als sie
masken schickte er keine masken wie wir
sie haben masken nach deutschland hat
man ihnen nicht gedankt man nur den
anderen ländern gedankt die masken
schickten man den namen taiwan nicht
erwähnt das zeigt dass europa in
sonderheit auch deutschland muss
aus dieser haltung heraus es braucht ein
bekenntnis zu den westlichen werten und
zu den westlichen werten gehörten die
amerikanischen werte ebenso wie die der
französischen revolution und die können
eigentlich zusammen und darf ich nur
noch ganz kurz dass das beklagen der
sparte spaltung das ist ja spaltung ist
ja das wollte stunde aber kennedy 1960
0,1 vorsprung gewählt prozent vorsprung
gewählt kennedy wurde ich glaube drei
jahre nachher erschossen ich meine im
moment gibt es sowas überhaupt nicht auf
der agenda dass die gewalttätigkeit so
weit gehen könnte also es war waren sind
orte wo spaltung ausgetragen wird
spaltung heißt nicht dass hat zeigen
sehr gut gesagt mache reden wir
miteinander
aber wir bleiben natürlich dran piano
und demokraten ist ganz klar was das
problem ist bei tram ist die
persönlichkeitsstruktur und sei das
versteht der auch nicht ich glaube er
weiß gar nicht was populismus ist
populismus ist den gegner zum feind
erklären das tut er ununterbrochen im
eigenen land in der demokratie man kann
einen diktator zum feind erklärt man
muss aber doch nicht demokraten in der
demokratie das tut er
er hat dieses kann schmetzer verständnis
dass man eigentlich unter freund feind
politik macht frau pohl wenn wir jetzt
unabhängig davon ob donald trump im amt
bleibt oder nicht konstatieren dass sich
das tanzpaar das transatlantische
verhältnis geändert hat und auch nicht
mehr so wird wie es früher einmal war
kann man dann vielleicht sogar sich bei
donald trump bedanken dass er im prinzip
die politische wiederauferstehung
europas gefördert hat damit europa in
zukunft eben auch ein global player wird
neben den usa neben russland neben china
neben möglicherweise noch anderen
staaten ist das sozusagen ein
förderprogramm für europäische
souveränität und selbstbewusstsein
wir müssen uns vergegenwärtigen dass
präsident barack obama angefangen hat
mit der militärischen doktrin leading
from behind sagt also führen von ich
übersetze es jetzt mal wörtlich von
hinten also nicht mehr so wie sich wie
die amerikaner die vereinigten staaten
sich jahrzehnte lang sozusagen
präsentiert haben der kollege hat so
sagt als weltpolizisten davon hat sich
barack obama schon verabschiedet nicht
mehr sagt wir sind vorne dran und zeigen
der welt wo es lang geht sondern wir
unterstützen sozusagen als teil der
gruppe von hinten legen from behind es
hat präsident obama angefangen und
präsident trump in der tat fortgesetzt
der ehemalige us also deutsche
botschafter in washington wittich hat in
dem deutsche welle interview jetzt
kürzlich gesagt dass er persönlich
donald trump tatsächlich diesbezüglich
als wake up call also als wachruft auch
durchaus wahrgenommen hat der dringend
nötig war essinger der organisator ghani
sator der mich nur sicherheitskonferenz
hat ähnliches gesagt also da hat sicher
donald trump in seiner politik
deutschland und europa vor augen geführt
dass wir nicht länger uns hinter den usa
in der art und weise sozusagen
verstecken können wie wir das seit da
letztendlich mit dem mit der neuen
nachkriegsordnung durchaus getan haben
das heißt es wird jetzt auch langsam
ernst denn diese ankündigung haben die
amerikaner ja schon häufiger gemacht ihr
europäer liszt mehr tun das würde auch
unterschreiten gar nicht anders sein
ja wahrscheinlich aber absolut gegen die
frage gegen verleihen
aber ich denke dass job ein wenn auch
noch mal bestätigen dass wir trotzdem da
sind also von rampen glaube ich gibt es
jetzt der gefühl das gefühl dass amerika
kein verlässlicher partner ist und das
wollen wir nicht mehr so lassen also wir
werden trotzdem da sind sie da sein aber
natürlich sollte ja ein bisschen mehr
für sich selbst machen wenn wir jetzt
mal wir fahren ja im moment auf sicht
was die nächsten tage und wochen in den
usa angehen da muss man schon gut in
spekulieren sein und oder
noch besser hellseher um das jetzt raus
zu kriegen es gibt ja einen
verfassungsmässigen weg am 8
dezember müssen die wahlergebnisse der
bundesstaaten beglaubigt sein am 14
dezember drehten die wahlmänner zusammen
wählen das ergebnis wird aber erst im
neuen jahr am sechsten januar
bekanntgegeben am 20 da steht in der
verfassung dann die vereidigung des
neuen präsidenten kann da amerika in
dieser verfassungsmäßigen vorgabe das
steht ja tatsächlich in der
amerikanischen verfassung da noch vom
rechten weg abkommen und was würde das
bedeuten wenn man die verfassung gar
nicht mehr einhalten könnte also ich
glaube wir finden uns doch auf der
richtigen weg also ich hoffe also der
herr wolf meyer das auch bestätigen
wurde dass wir wollen unsere demokratie
bereiten also verstehen dass wir haben
ja schon gesagt es ist wirklich der herz
unseres land das für eine richtige wahl
machen wir werden jede stimme zählen und
an inter kommen ganz zufrieden raus also
zumindest dass wir wissen wir haben das
richtig gemacht
da stehen wir immer dahinter wir werden
trotzdem weiter kämpfen dass wir gucken
dass jeder stimme gezählt wird
und ja dann gucken wir weiter wie das
dann im januar ist das wäre irgendwie
zusammen kommen können
ich wollte ja jetzt da haben sie ja
angekündigt dass die republikaner die
gerichte bemühen werten um klar zu
machen ist das alles mit rechten dingen
in der vergangenen nacht abgegangen und
auch in der zeit davor mit dem early
voting
am ende könnte das ja alles dort landen
wo die republikaner mit juristen die der
partei nahestehen eine klare mehrheit
haben nämlich beim supreme court in
washington auch durch die berufungen das
wären immerhin drei die donald trump in
seiner amtszeit jetzt dort vorgenommen
hat offensichtlich auch in der absicht
dass das richter sind die nicht
unbedingt gegen ihn urteilen werden
setzen sie in diesem supreme court mit
dieser 623 konservativen mehrheit große
hoffnungen
das kann natürlich am ende sein dass es
vom supreme court entschieden wird
jetzt warten wir doch einfach mal ab es
geht ja jetzt erst mal an die gerichte
in michigan und es gibt halt diese
neuauszählung in wisconsin und die
anderen staaten müssen ja auch noch
erklärt werden
obwohl daher das ergebnis relativ klar
ist bis auf der isola und dann schauen
wir einfach mal wenn es am schluss der
supreme court entscheidet also keiner
wird ja jetzt hoffentlich den richtern
unterstellen dass sie sympathisch sind
dass sie einfach dann dem präsidenten
dem sie sozusagen ihren ihren sitz im
supreme court verdanken einfach dann
durch winken also das hoffe ich dass wir
uns da schon darauf einigen können dass
diese unabhängig sind dass sie das eher
trennen können da möchte ich gerne sagen
natürlich da kann ich völlig zustimmen
was sie gesagt hat mit der demokratie
aber das beinhaltet auch natürlich
lieber emily dass wenn donald trump dann
präsident bleibt dass die demokraten
nicht wieder wie er in der ersten
amtszeit die ganze zeit wie ein bockiges
kind sich benehmen und nur überlegen wie
sie den präsidenten des amtes entheben
können sondern dann in wichtigen sachen
erstmal zusammenarbeit an gesagt dass
bevor dann der nächste wahlkampf muss
ich jetzt wie ein politisches happy end
ganz kurz nur noch 30 sekunden hatte
trump strategische vorarbeit geleistet
mit den richtern am supreme court was
man sie auch ein politiker setzt wenn
der richter durchbringen kann immer
seine politik ein aber ich glaube auch
dass richter rechte sind und da würde
ich auch nicht einfach das merkmal ja
vor allen dingen unabhängigkeit ist
natürlich richter und unabhängige müsste
eigentlich identisch sein
gut dann bedanke ich mich für die
diskussion bei ines pohl bei benjamin
wolf meyer bei emily lions und bei frank
meyer liebe zuschauer morgen in der
phoenix runde bleiben wir beim thema was
bleibt uns auch anderes übrig das thema
morgen gespaltene welt macht die usa
nach der wahl sicher auch mit neuen
details dann zum wahlausgang und wie es
in den usa weitergeht
jetzt folgt der tag mit konstanzer platz
geben auch da geht es auch die us-wahl
und den stand der ermittlungen in
österreich nach dem terroranschlag von
wien bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]